christian police have now identified the  gunman who opened fire in a southwest  tennessee supermarket police say 29 year  old ook thang shot 15 people inside of a  gross kroger's grocery store killing one  before turning the gun on himself his  motive isn't known yet they say he  worked at a kroger's on a daily basis  and seemed to be shooting at random  first responders triaged wounded as  customers and employees tried to  file out with their hands in the air we  removed people from freezers closets  hiding between pallets of groceries  police say recent active shooter  training enabled them to respond quickly  and save more lives